prince harry is back in california
following his grandfather prince
philip's funeral
but now a source close to the royal
tells e.t
he would have liked to stay in the uk
longer the sussex is i think feel very
far away from us
over here in the uk they're they're
unallah now that they're based in the us
and i think we're seeing quite a
distinction here between the cambridges
really
flying the flag for the royal family and
the sussex is creating
a new life for themselves in l.a the
source explains that while the 36 year
old
is grateful he was able to spend some
time in london
he quote wished he'd been able to stay a
bit longer
i know that prince harry was very
nervous ahead of coming over to the uk
for the funeral of course this was the
first time he had seen members of his
family
in over a year and i think it very much
was the case that he
got the cold shoulder from some members
of the family not his father
not his brother and not the duchess of
cambridge and despite the reports that
some interactions with his family were
cold
the source tells e.t he welcomed the
opportunity to reconnect
especially since covid has prevented him
and his wife meghan markle from
traveling to the uk
over the last year the talk at the
palace is that they are
absolutely horrified by what has been
said
they feel that harry has literally
thrown the family under a bus
of course the duke of sussex's trip to
the uk comes on the heels of a reported
falling out between harry and his older
brother prince william
after harry and megan's bombshell
interview with oprah winfrey
things were not going to be resolved in
one or two family meetings so while this
has been
an important step there's clearly still
a lot of hurt
a lot of resentment and a degree of
mistrust
i think on both parts e.t source says
harry and william have been working on
the commemoration to their mother
princess diana
scheduled for later this summer on what
would have been her 60th birthday in
july
the source adds that while relationships
were raw in the aftermath of the oprah
interview
both brothers remained fully committed
to carrying on diana's legacy
jointly i think the hope is that come
july when we are hoping to see the
brothers
stand once again shoulder by shoulder to
unveil
the statue in memory of their mother
that the relationship will be
stronger and in a better place earlier
this week the palace announced that
princess diana's 1981 wedding gown is
set to go on display at kensington
palace in london
this summer the gown which was designed
by elizabeth and david emanuel
was worn by diana during her wedding to
prince charles
with diana she she chose us because she
was used to the designs that we did she
liked them
felt comfortable the dress is now owned
by william and harry who have loaned it
to the hrp for the exhibit
the brothers are also planning to unveil
a statue of their mother
at kensington palace this summer in
honor of what would have been her
milestone
60th birthday
you